in a career that has led her to serve as
the head of the un's human rights
monitoring mission in ukraine matilda
bogner has seen more horrors than she
can recall but never anything like this
compared to the other conflicts i've
worked on the intensity
is much higher the numbers of victims
over a short period of time is is much
higher than i have personally seen
in in other conflicts
executions force disappearances
rapes there are few limits to the
violations of international law u.n
monitors are investigating in ukraine
bogner's team of 60 have started looking
into 300 unlawful deaths those are just
the ones that they're aware of from
liberated areas around the capital a
fraction of the overall deaths in
ukraine we can't go to places like
mariupol
we can't go to places where there is
severe hostilities it's just too
dangerous
so i would say that's one of the biggest
constraints when those locations become
accessible bogner says the work of her
team will only expand
already she says nearly every person she
and the team have met have a personal
story of death that requires
documentation
their work to record everyone
is no guarantee of justice
prosecuting war crimes is an onerous
legal undertaking that can take years i
think even just documenting and making
public what is happening is a form of
sort of accountability at least at the
more social social level bearing witness
to horrors of war is painful painstaking
work bogner and her teams share a solemn
sense of duty knowing what they
catalogue here could help how one day
history is remembered and possibly
accounted for
crystal gomanson global news kiev
ukraine